by the way breaking news elon musk
officially about twitter okay oh damn
twitter must strike a deal for takeover
it's a done deal let's read the story
can you go up so you can zoom in i can
read that title go up a little bit go up
a little bit go up a little bit zoom in
control plus control plus
uh okay so let's see right there twitter
inc on monday accepted elon musk to take
over the company given
the world's richest man controlled
influential social media network where
he is also among its powerful users the
deal marks the close of a dramatic court
trip courtship and a sharp change of
heart at twitter where many executives
and board members initially pose musk's
takeover approach the deal
has polarized twitter's employees and
users and regulators over the power tech
giant
wheeled in determining the parameters of
acceptable discourse on the internet and
how companies enforce their rules the
two sides work through the night to hash
out a deal earlier on monday the wall
street journal reported twitter mr must
reach an agreement to value twitter at
44 billion dollars a takeover if it goes
through would mark one of the biggest
acquisitions in tech history and most
likely we have
global repercussions for years to come
related to how billions of people use
social media musk who is also the ceo of
tesla and space exploration technology
must find a way
to balance his commitment in less
moderation with the business needs of a
company that has struggled to reconcile
freewheeling conversations with content
that appeals to advertisers on monday uh
after the journal reported that a deal
was closed mr
indicated tweeted to indicate that he
wants the platform to remain
destination for wide-ranging discourse
and
the disagreement i hope that even my
worst critics remain on twitter because
that is what free speech is all about so
five step on what this guy's gonna do
move number one he bought twitter move
number two he's gonna take a private
move number three okay and what this
guy's gonna that's gonna piss off a lot
of people okay he's gonna bring jack
back okay he's gonna bring jack back
jack dorsey because jack left because
it's just worse than working out with
the board everybody thought jack was the
bad guy jack didn't own 51 the company
when he left he only owned a couple
percent when he left he'll bring jack
back
he will eliminate tom brady's picture
from the combine because that's what he
owes to him
and then he's gonna bring the guy back
that's gonna when he does that forget
about it
when he does what when he brings back
your best friend he brings trump back
which he was a student of yours by the
way we got we got i got great stories
with the trumpster wait
you want me to get into that so he's
coming back on twitter so if trump comes
back and if if there's anybody that's
going to bring true trump back on
twitter it's going to be who it's going
to be it's going to be elon if he look
at that picture right there when uh when
um looking thick i didn't i haven't seen
that shot i didn't teach him
anyway so so so that story is official
wow and this guy if you would how
excited are you right now you know what
i'm excited about i'm excited about the
fact that people can officially go out
there and say stuff and not have to
worry about every other award is going
to be uh taken out of context and
they're going to be taken down i think
people are free if you enjoyed this
short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]